Успішне сільське господарство починається зі ставлення до землі. Поле - це та ж хата, де не повинно бути ні камінців…
Камінці потрапляють на поле з траси, і це завжди проблема для техніки. Тож я його збираю.
Ні якогось сміття.
Так само я чиню, коли бачу сміття, пластик - усе забираю.
Це девіз німецького фермера Йоганна Венцля, який вже 18 років займається сільським господарством на Черкащині.
В селі під назвою Роги він заснував ТОВ з іноземним капіталом "Дукра Агро".
Наразі орендує земельні паї у мешканців 5-ти сусідніх селищ, обробляє майже 4500 гектарів і вирощує пшеницю, кукурудзу, ріпак та цукровий буряк.
Чудове,  здорове листя. Ми вже двічі обробили буряк проти шкідників і грибків.
Отак має виглядати буряк у цю пору. Супер! Думаю, ми зберемо 80, а може, й 100 тонн з гектара.
1 липня в Україні відкрився ринок землі, і німець абсолютно щиро вважає, що за теперішніх умов ринку продавати такі родючі землі зовсім не варто.
З точки зору німецької практичності, продаж, принаймні в умовах Черкащини, наразі видається невигідним.
Розрахунок німця такий. Він платить за пай в середньому 15 000 гривень на рік. Ринкова вартість гектару чорнозему наразі на Черкащині приблизно 34 000 грв.
Виходить, що власник паю продає його за ціну, яку б він міг би отримати з оренди за 5-7 років.
Поки жоден пайщик з земель, які орендує німець, не висловив бажання продати свій пай.
Але на випадок подібної ситуації німець знає, що може запропонувати.
Ми робимо усе, аби наші пайщики залишилися з нами. Ми хочемо і далі працювати з цими селами.
Тобто не лише платити їм оренду, а робити щось і для їхньої інфраструктури.
Також коли люди мають фінансові проблеми, то приходять до нас. Байдуже де.
Ми спілкуємося, люди пояснюють, що, мовляв, треба гроші, і ми пропонуємо їм укласти договори довгострокової оренди,
отримавши частину орендної плати наперед. І так люди і гроші отримують, і пай зберігають.
Німецьке підприємство дуже ретельно стежило за усіма законодавчими земельними ініціативами і аналізувало ухвалені досі закони.
Підприємство навіть провело у селах круглі столи з пайщиками, аби розповісти про ці закони та дати поради зі своєї німецької точки зору.
Щодо відкриття ринку землі, ми це питання аналізували, з нашими юристами радилися.
Висновок зараз такий: ми рекомендуємо, як підприємство, людям в перший рік-два не продавати їхню землю.
Тому що немає ціни, і, відповідно, ті люди,  які будуть поспішати, вони  можуть дуже багато програти.
У місцевій Маньківській громаді  усього 19 селищ. Подібні пропозиції від німецького підприємства тут вітають.
Адже промислових підприємств в ОТГ немає, тому головний прибуток громади, яка має утримувати всю свою соціальну сферу,
лише від аграріїв, зокрема від плати за оренду.
Для громади сьогодні найкращий варіант - це  оренда землі. Від оренди ми маємо надходження.
Ринок землі для органів місцевого самоврядування, моє особисте бачення:
держава повинна прийняти закон про банк, який би надавав кредит місцевим органам влади,
щоб ми за нормальний відсоток могли купити і бути першими покупцями у людей, хто бажає її  продати.
Щоб ця земля залишалася в комунальній власності громади.
Голова ОТГ наразі ініціював ревізію усіх земель, аби знати, де, хто на яких умовах їх орендує,
аби перевірити чи всі платять податки та оренду, і відповідно скласти план надходжень до бюджету.
Керівник громади - відвертий противник продажу землі як вітчизняним фермерам та підприємствам, так і іноземним.
Для нього найкращий варіант - коли в ОТГ працює успішне підприємство з німцем на чолі,
який не лише справна платить податки і допомагає громаді, а ще й змінює менталітет селян.
Якщо це робочий день починається о 7-ій, то воно  видно.
Якщо це обід-година, то теж видно. Тобто от ця пунктуальність німецька вражає позитивно.
Це людей в першу чергу зобов’язує до дисципліни, а дисципліна - це сказано все.
Місцеві мешканці по-різному ставляться до ринку землі.
Те, що продавати і купувати землю можна, вони здебільшого вважають позитивним кроком вперед.
Охочих купити землю замало, а ті, хто можуть продати, ставляться до теперішніх ринкових умов з пересторогою.
Земля в Черкаській області 1200 доларів за гектар.
Міністр сільського господарства України говорить, що в середньому буде гектар землі коштувати 50 000 грв.
Це не дуже велика ціна. За ці гроші не збагатієш. Біля 80% не хочуть такого ринку землі.
Вони хочуть цивілізованого європейського, щоб ціна земельної ділянки в Україні була, як у Європі.
Я вам скажу, що землю продавати - це останнє, що можна зробити. Ринку не дадуть збуту і до банкрутства усіх доведуть. Ось побачити!
От ці латифундисти, що тримають наші усі пайочки. В Одесі скажуть, що там погана пшениця, або ще щось. Раз збитки, другий раз битки.
Розведе руками  і скаже, мовляв , вибачте, не хочу собі збитку. А що люди будуть робити? Вони будуть по 1000 доларів продавати!  Це ж старі в основному!
Я маю пай в три га. На сьогоднішній день його ціна досить маленька - 4500 доларів.
Я вважаю, що не треба продавати. Людям пообіцяли по 5 -10 000 доларів і всі думають за гроші,
щоб  їм одразу дали, але не думають про майбутнє, не усі розуміють.
Усі мешканці ОТГ чули або особисто знають, як працює у них в районі німець Йоганн Венцль.
Здебільшого вони вважають, що саме таких іноземців варто пускати на українські землі. Та чи слід їм їх продавати? Тут думки розділилися.
Іноземців, я думаю, варто пускати і здавати їм в оренду. Вони можуть дати набагато більше, ніж наші.
Іноземців можна допускати, тільки не всіх.
Німецький фермер з гордістю демонструє DW свою пшеницю та кукурудзу.
Для нього головний показник майбутнього доброго врожаю - здоровий вигляд рослин.
Німець у сільському господарстві з дитинства і знає багато різних таємниць.
Цього він вчить місцевого агронома, який опанував не лише німецьку мову, а й німецький підхід до роботи.
Зараз щодо забезпеченості сортами, гібридами, добривами і засобами захисту на ринку всі підприємства в рівних умовах.
Те, що німецького в нашій технології, то це лише порядок і своєчасність  виконання і обов’язковість дотримання вимог технології вирощування.
У нас деякі дивляться, що, може, я сьогодні не буду робити, може, якось так пройде. Іноді воно потім виходить боком.
Працювати за німецьким порядком, зізнається агроном, на початку було важко, але селяни навчилися.
Адже майже кожного року бачать результат - кращий урожай, ніж у сусідів.
Йоган Венцль намагається забезпечити своїх пайщиків роботою та зарплатнею у будь-яку пору.
От, приміром, аби трактористи не стояли без роботи, він дає додатковий підряд на будівництво ангару для техніки.
Німецький фермер вірить, що його бізнес в Україні, навіть попри заборону продажу земель іноземцям, залишатиметься прибутковим і перспективним.
Він не виключає, що українські політики та урядовці зрештою можуть переглянути цю норму.
У політиків важке завдання.  Я розумію, що реформа не може відбутися за одну ніч.
Політикам треба збирати досвід, треба йти до людей, спілкуватися з ними.
Але, звісно, нас як підприємства це теж стосується.
У нас, здається, 1600 пайщиків, і ми хочемо далі працювати на цих землях, щоб землі не були розпорошені в результаті продажу.
Ми хочемо мати гарні площі і добре на них господарювати.
Німець не горить бажанням скупити всі ті землі, які орендує.
Водночас не виключає, що у разі дозволу продажу іноземцям, може викупити певну частину.
Наскільки це буде необхідно, покаже земельний ринок, який в Україні ще тільки на початковій стадії.
До 2024 року до 100 гектарів землі можуть купувати дрібні та середні фермери.
За першу половину липня, за офіційними даними, було укладено приблизно 500 договорів купівлі-продажу.